previously on ill gotten gains daddy
likey huh am i right guy hmm I think I'm
ready now wait who's flying the plane
ouch that plane crash gave me some back
pains but it ain't stopping me from
tapping into the second half of
ill-gotten gains this second helping
brings more clothes vehicles and weapons
for you some are tasty some are a bit
bland but regardless let's dig in if you
weren't satisfied with ill-gotten gains
part ones tat selection good news 15
more tats hit the parlour some of which
are insane yo look at all that ink once
you get your ink fix cover that regret
up with hundreds of new clothing items
new items like overcoats sweaters
watches jewelry scarfs will help you to
hide up those tats from Grandma this
inspector gadget outfit works great for
me now it's time to purchase some new
hardware to new weapons the knuckle
duster comes in 8 pimpy models here we
have the player let's put it to the test
beautiful the marksman pistol add some
platinum to give it that sweet shine in
first person unfortunately it's a single
shot so it's not ideal for holy [ __ ] oh
my oh my god it's a hand cannon alright
I'm over the spot as well as this whip
time to invest in one of six new whips
well seven if you count the boat yeah
right well let's take a look at the coil
brawler hello is there anybody out there
looking for a good time shut up great
vanilla brawler is tasty but help out
those minds well you're looking at a few
bumpers spare tires and some roof lights
but aside from this cars mods this
update brings three new horns two of
which are loot definitely going with
flight of the bumblebee in fact this car
just became one oh yeah unfortunately
the rooftop lights don't seem to work
that ain't stopping this be from buzzin
what up
you miss me hey where you going oh hey
Oh Daniel wait you're hooking its on
baby Jim
Oh what
oh let's see that again
Oh
Moore's mutual have a nice day
damn these streets are crazy
you
you